If you grew up anywhere near Winston-Salem, North Carolina...
...then you've known since 1937 how delicious Krispy Kreme donuts are.
Gradually in the 40s and 50s, they expanded from just selling to local restaurants...
...to opening a few stores.
In the 1960s, the company again expanded, a little bit more geographically,...
...then the founder died; and in the 70s the company was bought by Beatrice, the large conglomerate.
In the early 90s, the company was bought back by the managers of Krispy Kreme...
...and taken public; and since then it's been a public company.
For specific financial data on Krispy Kreme, go to their website krispykreme.com.
Click on "Investor Relations",...
...and up should come all of the historical financial data on the company while it's been public.
Krispy Kreme became public with a bang...
...and was quickly the darling of Wall Street and eaters alike.
Since then, they've had a difficult time managing their stores profitably...
...and managing the distribution side of their business profitably.
As a result today with the share price in the dollar and a half range,...
...you'll have to make your own investment decision...
...on whether you'd like to participate in the future growth of Krispy Kreme.
They're delicious no matter what.
May the Kreme be with you.
I'm Roger Groh with Groh Asset, thank you very much for spending time with me.